putting a stop to Iran's nuclear program
has emerged as one of the most divisive
issues for world leaders meeting in
Biarritz France French president de
Manyu and Matt call says it's been
informally agreed he should approach
Tehran in the name of the g7 but US
president Donald Trump denies having
even discussed the question Trump pulled
the u.s. out of the international Accord
on Iran last year here's what the US
president had to say about any new
approaches to Tehran mr. president did
you sign off our statement to Iran a
message to Iran that president Makran
says he's going to deliver on behalf of
all the g7 countries no I haven't
discussed you know we can't stop people
from talking if they want to talk they
can talk and ews Georg mattis joins us
now from this summit India hates Georg
earlier we heard that the g7 wants a
president McCaul to send a message to
Iran but that no longer appears to be
the case is that right
it looks indeed like Donald Trump is not
ready to ease tensions with Tehran in
there there's something the French
president really hopes to achieve with
this g7 meeting he met up prior to the
g7 with a firm with the Iranian Foreign
Ministry he had a phone call with the
Iranian president he worked very hard on
that front Eric we heard yesterday from
diplomats here that there was even the
idea circled that Europe could buy some
oil from Iran in return for a number of
favors and for Iran sticking to the
rules for instance holding their feet
still they're not not not causing more
trouble in the Persian Gulf but none of
that valid today the American president
even denying like you've said that such
a discussion took place and the French
president tried to reduce the damage
just now by announcing that this is an
informal meeting they have debated
things they all agreed that peace in the
region is important and that Iran should
not get any nuclear weapons at least on
that front everyone agreed okay
in other developments at the g7 we
understand that the British prime
minister
Boris Johnson has been talking about the
likelihood of a brexit deal
what's he had to say while Boris Johnson
after meeting with Donald Trump
first of all announced that he has high
hopes for us
Britain free trade deal and of course
he's best desperate to provide some
positive news as something that will
make look brexit easy because after all
what he did not say is that Europe is
the biggest trading partner of the UK
and dropping out of the EU for the UK
will mean it will lose a whole set of
free trade deals that has already they
have already been arranged via the
European Union hammering out free new
trade deals is a is a lengthy issue and
this has on the on the second day here
at dawned a little bit apparently on
Boris Johnson when he said that the
Praxis deal outlook is is a little more
uncertain okay go speaking of trade
Donald Trump has denied the u.s. trade
war with China has been an issue during
these talks let's have a listen
no I think they respect the trade has to
happen - what about everything okay
since these comments and you just have
to follow me here the White House has
confirmed that President Trump actually
has no regrets on his approach with
China um has have his comments hindered
today's conference and discussions at
all it's another example of this back
and forth we've seen from the American
president for instance when it comes to
Iran now on that front it was else well
it raised quite some eyebrows here when
the White House clarified that what he
meant by regretting - SQLite tension is
is that he meant to it not even get
higher tariffs on China the whole
tit-for-tat trade war with China is a
big concern here the hope was that this
summit could help bring about new rules
how the world economies can deal with a
China that is drowning the world market
with cheap products they're subsidized
products from China but we're moving
further away from a solution that
President McCall could present at the
end of this g7 meeting okay DWS Georg
mattis in Biarritz thanks for that